[Music]
the only man not wearing a mask mourning
the loss of his mentor north korean
leader kim jong-un helped carry the
casket of the army marshal who groomed
him to become supreme leader
kim's ascension kim jong-un the current
guy his ascension wasn't guaranteed
there were other sort of possibilities
that a lot of people thought there might
be a military coup for example because
he wasn't really very well known he had
been living outside of the country for a
while and so my sense is that this is
somebody who helped him along and that's
probably you know what this
was this is one of the most senior
military leaders to have died in north
korea since the kovid 19 pandemic began
north korea denied the very existence of
the pandemic until last week now its
state media are reporting millions of
people are sick with an unidentified
fever and that 65 people have died
north korean defectors and aid groups
say its health care system isn't ready
for an outbreak of this size i've been a
north korean i've seen that i've
actually seen them like cranking trucks
with the crank you know like back in
1937. you know i mean really they still
use that kind of stuff and there aren't
enough roads so even if we gave them the
vaccines that they need how they can get
them there so it's just gonna cut
through
the
the bottom tier of the society like a
scythe i mean it's going to it's going
to kill an enormous amount of people
north korea has resisted all
international offers of vaccines
including from neighboring south korea
we don't know what the consequences of
this omicron variant will be when it
spreads to a large number of people who
have never been in contact with covet
19. there are enough reasons to pay
attention to this with interest
analysts say the virus is surging while
north korea says its cases are subsiding
mass events like this funeral come at a
time when people are being encouraged to
stay home
as the leader mourns the health of his
nation remains unknown
leah harding al jazeera